Un rêve merveilleux, papa. »
Je chantais avec l'urgence et le désir brûlant
d'une fille de neuf ans qui avait réellement un rêve.
Mon rêve était de devenir actrice.
Et c'est vrai que je ne voyais personne qui me ressemblait
à la télévision ou dans les films.
Bien sûr, ma famille, mes amis et mes professeurs
me prévenaient constamment
que les gens comme moi ne réussissaient pas à Hollywood.
Mais je suis une Américaine.
On m'a enseigné à croire que chacun peut réussir n'importe quoi,
qu'importe la couleur de sa peau,
le fait que mes parents aient immigré du Honduras
et que je n'avais pas d'argent.
Je ne demandais pas que mon rêve soit simple,
mais qu'il soit possible.
A 15 ans,
j'ai passé ma première audition professionnelle.
C'était une publicité pour des abonnements au câble
ou des cautions financières, je ne me souviens pas.
(Rires)
Ce dont je me souviens,
c'est que la directrice du casting m'a demandé :
« Pourrais-tu le refaire ? Mais, cette fois, aie l'air plus hispanique. »
J'ai demandé : « Ah d'accord.
Vous voulez que je le fasse en espagnol ? »
« Non, non, fais-le en anglais, mais aie l'air hispanique. »
« Hé bien, je suis hispanique, je n'ai pas l'air d'une Hispanique ? »
Il y a eu un long silence gênant
et puis finalement :
« D'accord ma chérie, pas grave, merci d'être venue, au revoir ! »
J'ai mis le trajet du retour à comprendre que par « avoir l'air plus hispanique »,
elle me demandait de parler un mauvais anglais.
Et je n'arrivais pas à comprendre pourquoi
être une véritable Hispanique, authentique et réelle,
ne semblait pas vraiment compter.
Bref, je n'ai pas eu le rôle.
Je n'ai pas eu beaucoup des rôles que les gens voulaient me voir jouer :
la petite amie du chef de gang,
la voleuse à l'étalage insolente,
la cagole enceinte numéro deux.
(Rires)
C'était le genre de rôles où on cantonnait une fille comme moi.
Une fille considérée comme trop typée, trop grosse,
trop pauvre, pas assez sophistiquée.
Ces rôles étaient des stéréotypes
qui ne pouvaient pas être plus éloignés de ce que j'étais réellement
ou des rôles que je rêvais de jouer.
Je voulais jouer des personnages complexes, avec des facettes multiples,
des personnages maîtres de leur destin.
Pas des caricatures d'arrière-plan.
Mais, quand j'ai eu l'audace de le dire à mon agent --
c'est la personne que je paie pour m'aider à trouver des rôles --
il m'a répondu :
« Quelqu'un doit dire à cette fille que ses attentes ne sont pas réalistes. »
Et il n'avait pas tort.
Même si je l'ai viré, il n'avait pas tort.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Chaque fois que j'essayais d'avoir un rôle qui n'était pas un stéréotype mal écrit,
j'entendais :
« Nous ne cherchons pas de mixité pour ce rôle. »
Ou : « On l'adore, mais elle est trop spécifiquement ethnique. »
Ou : « Malheureusement, nous avons déjà un Hispanique dans ce film. »
Je recevais toujours le même message encore et encore et encore :
mon identité était un obstacle que je devais surmonter.
Et alors, j'ai pensé :
« Viens donc, obstacle.
Je suis une Américaine. Je m'appelle America.
Je me suis entraînée toute ma vie pour ça, je vais seulement suivre le script,
je travaillerai encore plus. »
Et c'est ce que j'ai fait, j'ai travaillé d'arrache-pied
pour dépasser tout ce qui n'allait pas chez moi, selon ces gens.
Je suis restée à l'abri du soleil pour que ma peau ne bronze pas trop,
j'ai dompté et lissé mes boucles.
J'essayais constamment de perdre du poids,
j'ai acheté des vêtements plus chics et plus chers.
Tout ça pour que, lorsque les gens me regardent,
ils ne voient pas une Hispanique trop grosse, trop typée, trop pauvre.
Ils verraient ce dont je suis capable.
Et peut-être me donneraient-ils une chance.
Et, ironie du sort,
quand j'ai enfin eu un rôle
qui allait me donner les moyens de réaliser mes rêves,
c'était un rôle qui exigeait que je sois exactement telle que je suis.
Ana dans le film « Ana »
était une Hispanique typée, pauvre et grosse.
Je n'avais jamais vu personne comme elle, comme moi,
maître de son destin.
J'ai voyagé à travers les États-Unis
et dans plusieurs pays grâce à ce film.
Les gens, quels que soient leur âge, leur origine ethnique ou leur morphologie,
se sont reconnus en Ana.
Une Américaine potelée de 17 ans d'origine mexicaine
luttant contre la norme sociale pour réaliser son rêve improbable.
Malgré ce qu'on m'avait dit toute ma vie,
j'ai constaté que les gens voulaient des scénarios sur des personnes comme moi.
Et que mes attentes irréalistes
de me voir représentée avec authenticité dans la culture
étaient aussi partagées par d'autres.
Le film « Ana »
a été un succès critique, social et financier.
« Génial, pensai-je, nous l'avons fait !
Nous avons montré que nos histoires ont de la valeur.
Les choses vont changer maintenant. »
Mais j'ai observé que très peu de choses se produisaient.
Il n'y a pas eu de tournant.
Personne dans le cinéma ne s'empressait d'écrire plus de scénarios
sur un public avide et prêt à payer pour les voir.
Quatre ans plus tard, quand j'ai joué Betty dans « Ugly Betty »,
j'ai vu le même phénomène se reproduire.
« Ugly Betty » a triomphé aux États-Unis avec 16 millions de téléspectateurs
et a été nommé pour 11 Emmy Awards lors de sa première année de diffusion.
(Applaudissements)
Malgré le succès de « Ugly Betty »,
il n'y a pas eu d'autre série télévisée
avec une actrice hispanique dans le rôle-titre
à la télévision américaine pendant huit ans.
Cela fait 12 ans
que je suis devenue la première et seule Hispanique
à avoir remporté un Emmy Award dans un rôle principal.
Ce n'est pas une source de fierté.
C'est une source de profonde frustration.
Non pas car les récompenses prouvent notre valeur,
mais parce que ceux que nous voyons s'épanouir dans le monde
nous apprennent à nous regarder,
à réfléchir à notre propre valeur,
à rêver de notre avenir.
Et chaque fois que je commence à douter,
je me souviens d'une petite fille qui vivait dans la vallée du Swat au Pakistan.
Je ne sais pas comment, elle a trouvé des DVD
d'une série télévisée américaine
dans laquelle elle a vu le reflet de son rêve de devenir écrivaine.
Dans son autobiographie, Malala a écrit :
« Je me suis intéressée au journalisme
après avoir vu que mes propres mots pouvaient changer les choses
et aussi en regardant les DVD de « Ugly Betty »
sur le quotidien dans un magazine américain. »
(Applaudissements)
Pendant mes 17 ans de carrière,
j'ai été témoin du pouvoir de nos voix
quand elles peuvent être présentes dans la culture.
Je l'ai vu.
Je l'ai vécu, nous l'avons tous vu.
Dans l'industrie du divertissement, le monde de la politique,
dans les entreprises, dans les évolutions sociales.
Nous ne pouvons pas le nier -- la représentation crée la possibilité.
Mais ces 17 dernières années,
j'ai aussi entendu les mêmes excuses
pour expliquer pourquoi certains peuvent être représentés dans la culture
et d'autres non.
Nos histoires n'ont pas de public,
nos vies ne résonneront pas dans la société,
nos voix représentent un risque financier trop important.
Il y a quelques années à peine, mon agent m'a appelée
pour m'expliquer pourquoi je n'ai pas eu le rôle pour un film.
Il m'a dit : « Ils t'ont adorée
et ils veulent vraiment introduire de la mixité dans les rôles,
mais le film ne peut pas être financé
tant qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé l'acteur blanc. »
Il a prononcé ce message le cœur brisé
et avec un ton qui disait : « Je comprends que ce n'est pas normal. »
Mais malgré tout, comme des centaines de fois auparavant,
j'ai senti les larmes couler sur mon visage
et la douleur du rejet s'emparer de moi,
puis la honte en m'en faisant le reproche :
« Tu es une grande fille, arrête de pleure pour un rôle. »
Pendant des années, je suis passée par là en acceptant que l'échec venait de moi,
puis en me sentant profondément honteuse de n'avoir pas pu franchir les obstacles.
Mais cette fois, j'ai pensé différemment.
Je me suis dit : « Je suis fatiguée de ça.
J'en ai assez. »
J'ai compris
que mes larmes et ma douleur ne venaient pas d'avoir perdu un rôle.
C'était la réaction à ce qu'on disait réellement de moi.
Ce qui avait été dit de moi toute ma vie
par des dirigeants, des producteurs,
des réalisateurs, des scénaristes, des agents,
des enseignements, des amis et ma famille.
Que j'étais une personne de moindre valeur.
Je pensais que la crème solaire et les fers à lisser
apporteraient du changement dans ce système de valeurs très enraciné.
Mais ce que j'ai compris à ce moment-là,
c'est que je n'avais jamais vraiment cherché à ce que le système change.
Je cherchais à ce qu'il m'inclue et ce n'est pas la même chose.
Je ne pouvais pas changer ce qu'un système pensait de moi,
alors que j'acceptais de croire ce que le système pensait de moi.
Pourtant, je le faisais.
Comme tout le monde autour de moi,
je croyais qu'il m'était impossible de concrétiser mon rêve telle que j'étais.
Et je me suis mise à essayer de me rendre invisible.
J'ai pris conscience qu'une personne pouvait
souhaiter sincèrement voir le changement se produire,
tout en agissant de telle sorte que les choses restent comme elles sont.
Ce qui m'a conduite à penser que le changement ne va pas arriver
en désignant les bons et les méchants.
Ce débat n'avancerait à rien.
Car la plupart d'entre nous ne sommes ni l'un, ni l'autre.
Il y aura un changement
quand chacun de nous aura le courage
de s'interroger sur ses valeurs fondamentales et ses opinions.
Pour ensuite veiller à ce que nos actions mènent à nos meilleures intentions.
Je ne suis que l'une de ces millions de personnes
à qui l'on a dit que, pour réaliser mes rêves,
pour faire don de mes talents au monde,
je devais m'opposer à la réalité que j'incarne.
Pour ma part, je suis prête à cesser de m'y opposer
et à commencer à exister pleinement moi-même.
Si je pouvais revenir en arrière et dire quelque chose
à cette fillette de neuf ans, dansant dans le salon, nourrissant des rêves,
je lui dirais
que mon identité n'est pas un obstacle.
Mon identité est mon super-pouvoir.
Parce qu'en vérité,
je suis ce à quoi le monde ressemble.
Vous êtes ce à quoi le monde ressemble.
Tous ensemble, nous sommes ce à quoi le monde ressemble vraiment.
Et pour que notre système le reflète,
il n'y a pas besoin de créer une nouvelle réalité.
Il faut seulement cesser de s'opposer à la réalité où nous vivons déjà.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)